on this saturday night on high alert
what we went through and that another
family is having to go through that
again
it's horrific the safety of british
politicians being questioned as the
killing of another mp is treated as
terrorism plus crisis in a calumet the
surgeons and the scrub nurses would be
washing their hands with contaminated
water the impact of high concentrations
of fuel in the city's latest water
crisis people who are consuming cannabis
as medicine are going in and relying on
these labels the dangers of canada's
cannabis mislabeling and why it's
happening
and nasa's lucy spacecraft launches on a
quest to study some of the solar
system's most fascinating rocks
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight mithu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight in britain where police
have declared the killing of
conservative mp david amos a terrorist
incident tonight residents gathered for
a candlelight vigil in the village of
leoncy where amos was viciously stabbed
yesterday multiple times the area now a
crime scene and the site of a growing
memorial in tribute to the long-serving
politician a 25-year-old suspect is in
custody the community is in shock
jennifer johnson has our top story
tonight
at the church where british lawmaker
david amos was killed leaders from
across the political spectrum gathered
to pay their respects the 69-year-old
conservative member of parliament was
stabbed multiple times while meeting
with local voters the investigation is
in its very early stages
and is being led by officers from the
specialist counter-terrorism command
police arrested a 25-year-old british
man at the scene and recovered a knife
the motive and if amos was specifically
targeted is still under investigation
searches are being conducted at two
london addresses many locals laid
flowers at the church saturday for the
popular politician and father of five
who had served in parliament for nearly
40 years when my son didn't know
what to do and how to go forward
he went to david and david helped him
get into the police and you know i just
felt that i needed to come and just pay
my respects
prime minister boris johnson says the
entire country is heart stricken the
reason i think people are so shocked and
saddened is above all he was one of the
kindest nicest most gentle people in
politics amos's death has reopened
questions about the security of british
parliament members it comes five years
after labor party lawmaker joe cox was
shot and stabbed by a far-right
extremist on a street before meeting
with her constituents the shock
and the
feelings for us as a family obviously as
to what we went through and that another
family is having to go through that
again
it's horrific the british interior
minister convened emergency security
meetings hours after the fatal stabbing
i've been with the speaker of the house
and with the police and our security
services to make sure that all measures
are being put in place for the security
of mp so that they can carry on with
their duties british lawmakers are
generally not provided armed security
outside of parliament but after this
second killing of a politician in five
years many say that has to change
jennifer johnson global news washington
to the situation in ecallute now tests
have turned up a high concentration of
fuel in a tank that supplies water it's
the third major water emergency for the
city in just the past four years and
another instance of the drinking water
issues that are an everyday reality for
many of canada's inuit and indigenous
communities let's bring in now nunavut's
chief public health officer dr michael
patterson dr patterson thank you so much
for joining us so first of all what
impact is this lack of clean tap water
in the city having on hospitals and the
overall health care system
for the most part the health care system
is functioning
and there has been no
no need for admissions for anyone who's
been
ingesting this water
but when we discovered that there uh
there was contamination with
hydrocarbons
the decision was made to
limit surgery to only those that
absolutely needed to be done and
could not
be done elsewhere and based on the
testing done so far how much of the
city's water supply has been
contaminated
right now we we expect that
some of this fuel has gotten into the uh
entire system but the highest
concentration and the levels that were
uh
the most concerning and dangerous were
confined solely to that one well the
level of contaminant drop with each step
through the process
and
that is probably what has kept us from
having more severe impacts at this point
having said that dr patterson we did
hear from some residents who said they
weren't feeling well after having
consumed that water before they were
told not to what kind of symptoms have
those who drank the water been reporting
we've heard of people
experiencing headaches
nausea some uh
vomiting and maybe some diarrhea
and who is most at risk of having any
health impacts uh from this contaminated
water especially given that we're in the
midst of a pandemic
the the biggest risk is always for
those who are already vulnerable
newborns and infants and
elderly would be at the highest risk of
severe problems from contaminants like
this
have you ever seen anything like this
before in your community
no
this is the first time
i've ever been involved with
any kind of
oil or fuel being in a municipal water
system all right we'll be in touch we'll
leave it there for now dr michael
patterson nunavut's chief public health
officer thank you very much
thank you
vaccinated canadians waiting to travel
to the u.s are feeling some relief now
that a date has been set for land border
crossings and a green light given to
those with mixed doses still many are
wondering what took so long and whether
it's a signal relations between our two
countries may not be so rosy michaela
couture reports
while in washington this week the deputy
prime minister's focus was mainly on
meetings with fellow finance ministers
of the g20 including u.s secretary of
treasury janet yellen the pandemic has
prevented some of these in-person
meetings but it shot a light on how much
that relationship needs attention
work needs to be done every single day
every single hour on the canada u.s
relationship
it comes as the u.s announced it was
loosening travel restrictions on both
its northern and southern borders at the
same time something canadian business
leaders worry is a sign we've lost our
friendly footing in the white house
we're being treated equally to the
mexican border come on there no the
borders are not treated equally they're
not created equally our rate of
vaccination is significantly better
a heider says there are a number of
other irritants canada continues to deal
with like defending the line 5 pipeline
lobbying against the buy america plan
and one other big issue we don't have an
ambassador we haven't had an ambassador
for over two years now you know i mean
it's supposed to be such a critical
relationship canada hasn't had a
permanent u.s ambassador since 2019 and
president joe biden's nominee david
cohen is being held up in congress on
the other hand some believe in the
post-donald trump presidency
canada may have gotten complacent so
biden gets elected and there's this sigh
of relief oh good
so you take your foot off the gas you
know what happens when you take your
foot off the gas like if you're in a
formula one race you take your foot off
the gas everybody zooms by you
canada made massive efforts during the
last free trade negotiations but those
efforts tailed off once the deal was in
place
to reengage greenwood says canada should
step up in areas the u.s could need help
like global vaccine efforts and the
resettlement of afghan refugees to the
extent that canada leans in to help
solve
some of the global challenges
it gives canada a bigger calling card on
some of the bilateral issues and it
could give canada a starting point as
the government looks to re-establish its
warm relationship with a long-time ally
and friend michael couture global news
ottawa
canadians have been waiting months for
some kind of national vaccine passport
to make travel easier tonight the public
safety minister says he's confident
something will be in place by the time
u.s land borders reopen on november 8th
abigail beeman is hosting the west block
this week abigail what did bill blair
tell you
nathu people have been waiting a long
time for a national vaccine passport
bill blair says they're still working
with provinces which hold the data to
make it happen but he thinks it will be
done in a matter of weeks so i asked him
whether that will be in time for the u.s
land border reopening november 8th i
always think it's important to over
perform and under under promise but at
the same time i'm i'm very confident
that that work has been progressing very
very well um and that we will have in
place for um
a number of canadian travelers that
certificate
by that date but but there's some
there's still some other contingencies
that need to be addressed we're working
through them as quickly as possible i
also asked blair about the messaging
around whether now is the time to travel
and about the question of travel for
nearly 4 million canadians who got a
mixed dose of the vaccine you can watch
the full interview sunday on the west
block neethu
thanks abigail
sunday marks three years since canada
legalized cannabis that lit up an
industry that's now worth four billion
dollars a year sales may be high but the
standards for cannabis labeling are too
low for one nova scotia scientist he
studies plant dna and says something
doesn't smell right ross lord explains
after studying the dna of cannabis
plants down to their smallest molecules
sean miles has come to a troubling
conclusion about how different strains
are marketed to canadians there's not
much difference for example products
whose dominant strain is advertised as
either sativa or indica each strain
supposedly producing a different
psychoactive effect it is frequently the
case that something that is labeled
sativa is still more closely related
chemically to something that's labeled
as indica than it is to anything else
that's labeled sativa right which means
that overall it's a poor predictor of
anything and not very useful miles says
for some cannabis consumers it's a big
deal people who are consuming cannabis
as medicine are going in and relying on
these labels of indica and sativa as a
kind of proxy for the medicinal content
of that plant and we've demonstrated
that that's it's not a good predictor of
those elements and so that's
particularly dangerous so why after
three years of sales licensed by the
federal government would legal cannabis
still be mislabeled the group that
represents more than 700 licensed
growers in canada suggests it's a
lingering effect from the illegal
cannabis market license holders were
able to bring
on a one-time basis uh bring plants over
from the illicit world where perhaps the
naming and such was uh
you know was more of a more of a trend
and less of a scientific matter the
cannabis council insists products are
tested rigorously before they go to
market but it admits inaccurate labeling
of different strains is still a problem
health canada says it's providing more
information for industry to ensure
packaging and labeling give consumers
the information they need
ross lower global news will fill nova
scotia
coming up kiwis roll up their sleeves in
record numbers for new zealand's
televised vaccine drive
and the world health organization's
latest push to understand the origins of
covid19
yeah this definitely helped sway my
decision yeah
at least two and a half percent of the
population of new zealand was vaccinated
in just one day today nearly 130
thousand kiwis rolling up their sleeves
for a nationally televised super
saturday vacathon new zealand had stayed
largely virus free until a delta
outbreak in mid-august and is now racing
to catch up on vaccinations
more than two dozen scientists from
around the world will lead a new panel
at the world health organization tasked
with better understanding how novel
pathogens like covet 19 start and spread
the who says this effort could be the
last chance to find the origin of this
pandemic reggie jacini explains
for nearly two years there's been one
question that scientists have struggled
to answer what caused the covet 19 virus
to infect humans and shut down the world
i would ask everyone countries
journalists
and everybody else to create a little
space
for that discussion to happen the world
health organization attempted to uncover
covet 19's origins earlier this year
sending scientists to china for a month
but beijing was accused of meddling in
the fact-finding so a new advisory panel
is being put together to focus not only
on covid but all problematic pathogens
the emergence of new viruses with the
potential to spark epidemics and
pandemics is a fact of nature
700 scientists applied to be on the
panel with 26 chosen from backgrounds
that include biosecurity and lab safety
a way to look into long push theories
over a leak from a chinese lab
every one of us stares at this and knows
the reality the reality this came from
wuhan the wh claimed human error was
unlikely early on but beijing's secrecy
has kept the theory simmering and the un
agency's director has called for further
research this group will work to balance
all theories this is our best chance
and it may be our last chance to
understand the origins of this virus in
a collegiate
collective and mutually responsible way
if there has ever been a moment to be
thinking about how to prevent pandemics
before they start and do it on a global
scale with global cooperation and
collaboration the moment is now the
advisory commission's ultimate goal is
to keep science front and center
creating a clear path to identifying
future diseases too meetings will be
confidential to cut out political noise
however one obstacle to overcome it
can't compel countries to participate we
need the cooperation of that member
state to carry out any future missions
but without a global effort work can
grind to a halt and disease experts say
the clock is ticking viral outbreaks are
common and tracing origins is a
monumental task reconstructing events
after the fact is always much more
difficult and the further away you get
from that event the harder it is to
collect the data now attempting to tie
up loose threads on a virus that's still
so unknown opportunity arises to learn
from past mistakes
reggie shakini global news washington
do big cities still mean bigger earnings
ahead why more canadians are cashing out
of that belief
there is a long-held belief that living
in bigger cities like toronto or
vancouver could mean access to higher
wages but recent research by a canadian
nobel laureate suggests the two don't
necessarily go hand in hand especially
when you factor in skyrocketing housing
prices and as ann gaviola explains it's
prompting more workers to go rural
dave battersby grew up in a small town
and he always knew he wanted to go back
and when kovitt hit he and his family
moved from toronto to coburg it was
extremely scary to pick up and move
during the pandemic a hybrid work
arrangement means he makes the hour and
a half long commute to toronto twice a
week he says small town life hasn't
dented his earnings but his living costs
are lower and they're in a much bigger
home mortgage-free we only had about a
thousand square feet there and when we
moved we moved to about 5000 square feet
the home we moved to
has a pool the kids have been enjoying
it every day since since we've moved
here throughout the summer months
findings released this week by
researchers at the university of
california at berkeley examined u.s data
between 2010 and 2018. it found that the
high cost of housing in big cities
erodes the advantage of a bigger salary
meaning you may benefit from more and
better amenities in an urban center but
you're typically not getting further
ahead financially along comes
a pandemic and this uh this hard shift
to working remotely businesses like mine
just transformed overnight and and
our staff that had always come into the
office were working from home the exodus
from downtown coors began about five
years ago as more people moved from
expensive urban centers to the suburbs
and rural areas with kovic giving rise
to flexible and hybrid work models royal
lepage highlights a big pickup in people
moving from ontario to the atlantic
provinces during the pandemic as well as
a migration from the lower mainland to
northern bc and parts of alberta
including calgary it's hard to find good
people and if you find the worker you
want that is not close to where your
office is you're going to be pretty
flexible about letting them work with
you despite rumblings this summer about
some big tech firms in the u.s like
facebook and google reducing pay for
workers who live in less expensive
cities economist linda nazareth says
that won't fly in this tight labor
market in an email to global news google
canada says outside the u.s each country
has a single compensation category so
there are no differences in pay whether
you're a fully remote or in-office
employee battersby says there are
trade-offs living in a smaller community
but they're worth it couldn't be happier
about our decision to move
it has really changed the lifestyle for
our family ann gaviola global news
toronto
next an alberta writers big break in a
blockbuster gaming franchise
three
two
one
zero
nasa blasted off on a 12-year mission to
explore jupiter's trojan asteroids these
space rocks are believed to be fossils
of the first planets so nasa named the
mission lucy after a famed collection of
fossils here on earth that discovery got
its name from the beatles song lucy in
the sky with diamonds nasa sent lucy
soaring with some lab made diamonds and
one of the beatles had a special
send-off as well
a little noisy but i'm so excited lucy
is going back in the sky with diamonds
johnny will love that anyway
if you meet anyone up there lucy give
them peace of love for me
well you don't need to be into video
games to know the name call of duty one
of the biggest franchises in the
industry well its action-packed latest
entry will be in the hands of players
next month but one edmonton woman
already plays a key part in its
storyline morgan black has more on the
budding designers big break
sometimes the only way to honor a fallen
soldier
is to finish the mission as a kid shelby
carlton spent hours in this world now
she's creating its next chapter to get
to like work on
a seminal game in my life
now is just
it's it's pretty crazy in her edmonton
home office carlton has been writing the
storyline for a best seller in the world
of video games
call of duty wade was the most dangerous
thing in the sky
after working on some indie titles she
applied to sledgehammer games a company
that's worked on the series in past
carlton was hired as a narrative
designer in march she began work on the
title i was very excited
she says there's much more beneath the
surface of the first player shooter game
i like to think of games now as as
empathy machines as these things which
can allow you to step into a story and
experience something that you may not
have experienced otherwise she knows
with a heavy hitting franchise comes
pressure the team worked with historians
and other experts to help shape the
narrative carlton helped shape another
storyline too her team was equal parts
men and women that should be how it is
everywhere and i hope that
that as much as i can be an example that
our team can be an example and that our
studio can be an example um for for the
wider industry she says creating her own
story is even more exciting than the
game she worked on morgan black global
news
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm nitu garcia tonight
your canada is canmore alberta the
mountains pictured here are called three
sisters we would love to see your corner
of the country so please keep sending
your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you